hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my arrow episode 20 video a lot
of stuff to explain with respect to the
Lazarus Pit and you know how it's gonna
affect the future of the characters
especially the big WTF decision that
Oliver made so I tried to include all
that stuff before I do top 5 moments I'm
gonna explain some of the stuff that
producers said after the episode so just
careful for spoilers if you if you
haven't seen episode 20 here we go so
Marc Guggenheim said that Thea coming
back in the lazarus pit is going to
spill over into season 4 like the the
after-effects even though it seemed like
she was back to normal by the end of the
episode like she was hating Merlin's
guts again there'll be a lot more
consequences that we just haven't seen
yet for the most part I think it's gonna
be memory personality trait type stuff
they've set her on the path to become
speedy the Mia Dearden speedy from the
comics so I think they're using this
Lazarus Pit personality change to kind
of course correct the character although
if they always intended for Laurel to
become the Black Canary then maybe they
always intended for Willa to become
speedy I can't get from the speedy thing
but like the first season when they were
hyping up arrow season 1 they mentioned
Laurel becoming Black Canary eventually
and this I don't remember specifically
if they ever said they always intended
for Willa to become speedy I know
there's a lot of confusion with respect
to the speedy name because speedy is
also the name for Arsenal red arrow Roy
just to be clear Roy was Arsenal he
wasn't red arrow and he didn't leave
arrow to go on the Teen Titans show you
know I don't think he's gonna get star
on that show that team is gonna be led
by Nightwing so here we go getting into
WTF top 5 moments starting with number 5
Willa dies on the operating table those
first couple of scenes were just meant
to tee up the impossible choice medical
science cannot save Thea there is only
one way to do that and that is for you
to join the League of Assassins
they already spoiled it in the promo so
we knew she was gonna end up in the
Lazarus Pit no mystery there we know
she's coming back it's not like they're
killing her off the show Merlyn actually
did a really good job of explaining the
logic of the Lazarus Pit with respect to
arrow
he said that in rare instances it could
bring people back to life as in like
it's not a regular thing you just can't
bring anybody back the way they
explained it in the comics is like
usually beyond a year it's impossible to
bring someone back and the longer
someone's dead the longer they're crazy
whenever they come back to life if you
compress the timeline a little bit just
assume that Willa was dead for about a
day maybe
less than a day Marc Guggenheim did
confirmed that they're not gonna use the
Lazarus Pit to bring back Tommy or Moira
queen he didn't say anything about caity
lotz though he was very careful to omit
Sarah from that conversation so he
neither confirmed nor denied that Sarah
would be brought back via Lazarus Pit as
the timeline stands right now it's still
within that one-year period so you know
technically if you're going on comic
book logic you could bring Sarah back
via the Lazarus Pit on to number four
ray and Felicity are officially done the
producers confirmed that those two
characters done forever not gonna happen
no more
so if you hated the two of them together
don't worry the nightmare is over I feel
like that's a pretty good move you know
if you want to take the Felicity
character seriously like if you really
want her to evolve then she has to exist
outside of these like ships that she's
part of meaning that like she can't only
exist inside these olicity moments like
she has to have her own personal
character moments that gets into season
four stuff there's there been a lot of
unconfirmed rumors that Felicity's
father is gonna be tied up with the
villain group and that'll be a path to
dive really deep into felicity character
development as in like you know Luke
Skywalker Darth Vader Empire type stuff
or I guess if you want to be more
specific you would say Princess Leia on
to number three Oliver and Felicity
finally do the thing even if you don't
give a crap about any of the ship stuff
this is actually a really big moment you
don't feel like the characters have been
building towards us for a while usually
when the writers indulge this kind of
stuff on on TV shows it ends up being
disappointing there have been a lot of
really good ships on screen I think I
think my favorite ship so far was odo
and Kira from Star Trek Deep Space Nine
and to be honest I don't really think
that comic book superheroes are allowed
to have positive relationships
Batman is a good example he has sexual
relationships with other characters like
Catwoman but that's not a healthy
relationship it's very dysfunctional
then you have like Talia al Ghul he has
a childlike he has a family but it's
incredibly dysfunctional so yeah it
totally works that Oliver and Felicity
get together but it's not gonna work out
the way everyone thinks it's gonna work
out it's gonna be incredibly messed up
and complicated I saw a lot of people
asking the composer of the episode on
Twitter and he confirmed that he was
putting the olicity sex music on the
season 3 soundtrack whenever they
released that so it might be on the DVD
so if you're a big olicity fan like you
will have that olicity sex track too Liz
to on to number two Thea's resurrected
in the Lazarus Pit this is a big step
forward in expanding the arrow cannon
like now magic officially exists someone
has been brought back to life they
needed to get there eventually because
the vixen the the digital series they're
working on is completely based on magic
and thus far it had not existed inside
the arrow universe so if you have any
questions about what exists what does
not exist in the arrow universe for that
for the most part it's all in there
magic special powers metahumans it's all
in there don't expect arrow to bring
Zatanna on anytime soon but I feel like
eventually they'll get there she really
feels like she'd fit better on the flash
where they do slightly more ridiculous
things I already explains a little bit
about the consequences that Marc
Guggenheim teased I I don't think we'll
find out what those are till we get
closer to the finale and we're late
there's only a couple more episodes it
seemed like she was willing to accept
Merlin's help like Merlin's like please
just let me take care of you and she
didn't say you know absolutely not so I
assume that that's gonna play out
Oliver is gone though he was like the
silver back of Starling city so I wonder
if Merlyn is gonna step in and be
something of a team leader right now he
is the most experienced person they have
Diggle would be the other choice so what
might end up happening is as Diggle will
step up and he will just like liaised
with Merlyn because they all still hate
Merlin's guts so it's not like they're
just gonna like take him in with open
arms but laurels gonna want to continue
with her mission his Black Canary
cleaning up the city you know wearing
the mask getting better she has her
canary cry too so she's gonna try that
out pretty soon Felicity ray they're all
gonna want to keep on helping people so
you know eventually I expect Willa to
put on a mask and start helping them out
too but there needs to be like someone
to help guide her so Merlyn will apply
continue to train her Diggle will
probably be the one to send them all on
missions like decide which missions they
take and finally my number one WTF
moment Oliver officially joins the
League of Assassins as alsa heme which
is just means arrow in Arabic I like how
his League of Assassins name is
literally the arrow I just think that's
funny did you notice he's actually still
wearing the little hosing around his
neck and there was a big like light bulb
moment I feel like in all of our heads
like collectively when they branded him
with the symbol that they've been using
for season four like usually it's the
hose in like the title card that was the
brand that they branded him with so that
just gives you an idea of how far in
advance they planned this season I know
a lot of
criticize arrow for borrowing from
Batman stories but Batman never became
head of the League of Assassins
typically like when Batman was
confronted with this situation he said
no I I don't have anything to do with
you ratio goal one really fun Easter Egg
two is that his costume his League of
Assassins costume actually invokes a lot
of his original Green Arrow costume
because they light the room so warmly
like it just you can't make colors out
it just all looks black but the hood in
the mask here are part green it was also
really cool to listen to Rachel Ghul
explain the true meaning of the word
assassin how it's been perverted over
time it just means someone who stands
apart from society all through the
comics in the animated series Rachel
goal has always put himself forward as a
protector of the earth so I'll be
interested to see if Oliver takes that
mission on to but just because he is the
new racial goal doesn't mean that Rachel
Ghul is going anywhere the original
racial goal and it's gonna go little
confusing when we talk about this here's
my big question for you guys you know
now that Oliver is the next racial goal
what do you think is going to happen
with racial goal is he gonna stick
around and train him is he gonna take
off really I don't think that we expect
him to go anywhere something is gonna
happen in the finale in racial goals the
original racial goal will continue to be
racial goal the really ballsy move
though I think would be to start arrow
season 4 with Oliver still part of the
League of Assassins they've been a lot
of rumors about time travel happening in
a flash finale I have no idea if that's
gonna change things on arrow it could so
I'll have to wait to see how the flash
show the flash finale affects what
happens on arrow one of my other really
favorite things about the episode is is
what Felicity did after they had sex she
wanted to get Oliver out of there so she
went ahead and concocted a plan on her
own and just went for it I think that
goes a long way towards addressing
complaints that Felicity's been spending
the entire season crying or just you
know riding shotgun so new episodes of
air on the flash next week be sure to
subscribe to get my videos I'm gonna try
and do a Q&A for this but I still need
to do agents of shield that's probably
gonna be my next video and I still have
some daredevil videos to do so I'm gonna
try and like work all that stuff in in
case you guys haven't seen it I did a
non-spoilery review for Avengers age of
Ultron
awesome movie make sure you guys go see
it in IMAX if you can and you can click
here for this week's episode of the
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow
you